i want to answer your question
but the pep is dancing on my tongue yeah
yeah yeah it's the show okay
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by megan the stallion
megan the stallion is a three-time
grammy award winner philanthropist and
soon-to-be restaurateur and franchise
owner with her new partnership with
popeye's louisiana kitchen starting
october 19th featuring the limited
edition release of the megan the
stallion hottie sauce keep an eye out
for that megan the stallion welcome to
the show i'm here i'm ready and
obviously i like hot stuff so
let's see if this is really a challenge
yeah what is going through your head as
you prepare to chow down today okay
honestly
when i sat down
can i curse yeah let it fly let it fly
like a [ __ ] werewolf boogeyman i
don't know this one is a volcano so
let's just see what it's getting this
one got like some radioactive [ __ ] on
the front so
let's see
[Music]
i feel like i can cage was hot as hell
going back in
the nugget was good there we go
okay
[Music]
that's fire
and pleasant right
i can do this
so with halloween right around the
corner i think now is as good a time as
any to talk about how your love of
horror movies has permeated your art
from appearing on the addams family 2
soundtrack to then conceptualizing your
web series your horror web series hotty
ween
do you have an all-time favorite horror
film reference in one of your music
videos thought [ __ ] has a couple of
extravagances yeah my favorite
would have to be the freddy krueger one
coming up yeah the hand coming out
because we got to twist it and make it
me and make it the long nails instead of
like the claw the knives um but i just
really like to be scared like i you know
it's probably because i like to be
surprised i like to be thrilled i like
to feel like oh my gosh what's coming
next and i feel like that's what i make
my hotties feel like when they listen to
my music like or just me as a person
like oh my god what is she gonna do next
what is her hair gonna be doing next
what does harnell's gonna be doing next
you know so
i like to scare people i like to
surprise people so maybe that's why i
like horror so much what did you mean
when you said we needed it for the
culture and reference to human centipede
human centipede when i was first
watching it i was like i know i know
ain't no way in here this movie about to
be about people mouth touching each
other ass
but i feel like that was something to
like crack your skull up and like that
just that was something that really like
blew my mind and i'm like you know what
this is going to push the next person to
come up with something even more
creepier and even more creepier and even
more out the box so you know pat on the
back make it if you said that because we
did need that
that one didn't feel like a hot sauce
i don't know what this tastes like
but it doesn't taste like a hot sauce oh
wait
he'd mean to throw it has a little bit i
think it hurt it i think it hurt it the
sauce is like what you say
i heard you but it doesn't taste like
hot sauce it just is hot
so as far as hip-hop origin stories go i
think making your name off ciphers is
one of the most unimpeachable ways to
really earn your stripes and in terms of
the radio freestyle shows you've really
made your mark on everything from sways
five fingers of death to fire in the
booth is there one of those in
particular that you've built up to be an
especially important notch in the belt
for real mc i feel like every time you
get in front of anybody in rap it's the
real deal and you got to go in every
time
when i first came out and i was doing
cyphers in houston and dallas and all
that i was like if i get the opportunity
to rap in front of anybody i'm gonna
give it my all because i don't know when
it's gonna be the last time so i always
go in like and treat it like this is
gonna be my first and last time doing it
so all of it is a writer passage when
you rap i really like to rap so
if i get to rap i'm gonna rap and i'm
gonna go hard every time but uh that you
know yeah every time you gotta go hard
so it's all like a rider passes to me
hoss sauce he got a little hat on with a
little feather
[Music]
i feel like y'all tricking me
like it's not um
it's not up to your level yet no
like what is this called hot one's a
cold one whoa
but maybe maybe megan maybe we're
lulling you into a false sense of
security right i'm like okay y'all got
to be doing something to me this
is psychological yeah like you trick
this
it might pipe up at this bright coloring
right here
just not giving me hot
well just wait just wait
it's like something on my nose
so you're coming off a massive year
multiple grammy wins one of the albums
of the year and good news and then
listening to it something that really
stands out is the layering how obsessive
are you about sound mixing in the studio
it takes me
at least like 10 tries to get the song
mixed perfectly
and even when i'm recording
i have to record it like five times so i
can make sure
i said it right and it felt good and you
could hear everything correctly because
i have a apparently i have a thick
accent
i don't hear it but that's what people
tell me so i'm like when i'm rapping i'm
like okay
let me try to make sure i say this clear
as possible with my same twang but as so
y'all can understand me
i'm in there with the engineer like i'm
like okay no it has to sound like this
no y'all change the beat which i'll do
to this turn this up do this so i'm very
you know particular about how my things
sound when they're all said and done
[Music]
what do you feel like is it hot
you know we've done hundreds of these
episodes so not everybody has that sort
of like texas chili mix what it is you
have like a good tolerance southern mix
but i'll also say this i've
sat across the table from many people
who in the front half are like what's
the deal crank it up yeah that's a much
different story later on down the line
give me let's get to the end we will
take me this way we will see we will see
so from merch collabs with crunchyroll
to modeling as todoroki on magazine
covers to saying that you'll pop out on
a hoe like pikachu on your song fantasy
pool party yeah your love of anime comes
through in everything that you do
what is the best anime in your opinion
to reach for when you need a laugh um a
laugh
okay i'm not gonna lie let's just talk
about the anime that i'm finishing right
now let's go i'm watching black clover
and it's so good and my favorite
character on the show is asta because
this [ __ ] is always screaming
and hollering like even if they like in
the middle of a fight like he'll just
bust out with like some goofy [ __ ] but
in the show everybody has magic
everybody born with magic but for some
reason also was born with like zero
magic so everybody would be like picking
on him like oh you ain't got magic
getting gonna be [ __ ] and then he was
like yes i am like
he was just like really going hard but
he doesn't have magic but that's what
makes him unique in the in the whole
world like so anytime anybody try to
fight him or like whoop on him they
can't because he has anti-magic so it
like cancels out everybody else matters
so he really like the coldest character
in the show and i just feel like i can
relate to him and any of the other like
main characters in anime because a lot
of people you know they try to count you
out when they feel like you know you
ain't [ __ ] or you ain't got something
yet but you know you train and you train
and you fight and you fight and you keep
proving everybody wrong you keep beating
the eyes and i feel like that's the type
of person i am
reaper pepper
that sounds like
you bout to kill my damn taste buds
[Music]
no problem
or maybe no it's funny
because i feel like you want me to be
like
no you know what i don't want you to be
and you know i know i can't tell you
this anyway but i just want you to be
real and i know megan the sallian's
always going to be real anyway so that's
all i would ask just keep it real just
keep it real
no problem with that one though this one
yes it starts kicking in yeah okay
i did talk [ __ ] i i talked sometimes
they hear you i think the peppers was
like activate
[Laughter]
she got us [ __ ] up okay
but you know what while you work through
that one we have a recurring segment on
our show meghan the stallion called
explain that graham we do a deep dive on
our guest instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context so we'll
pull up the picture over here on the
monitor you just tell us the biggest is
it
yeah oh it's yours okay
you are as melina the stallion yes do
you have any hot girl tips for mortal
kombat beginners and what draws you to
the game okay boom mortal kombat
beginners whichever one i'm supposed to
look at
get on google
pull up the cheat code
not the chico but pull up the chicos and
pick one remember it and i promise you
it don't matter who you playing against
you'll be [ __ ] him up with that one
move so that's really how i learned how
to play melina was the first person i
ever like
googled the code for
and i'll be killing everybody with her
and i don't care how long you've been
playing
but this is really like a sexy picture
to me
because the makeup is just on point the
titties are on point and then like it's
like the mouth is just like
i'll eat you
but it's still
but it's still fire and the bob come on
buy up like
it's cute the hell yeah all right up
next
what do you think was special about the
butter remix with bts that helped launch
it to a billboard number one i feel like
what was special about it was the fact
that we all really wanted to do it and
it was like a little trouble getting
there yeah
but we got through it and i feel like
everybody was so excited about it and i
was so excited to meet them they came to
new york
came they wanted to meet me i was like
y'all want to see me so uh we all went
up to roc nation and they came and they
met four and they gave us gifts and it
was just so cute i think they met the
dogs yes
of course he's here really yeah
he can't eat no no no yeah i gotta keep
a distance from the table right but he
would eat it if he could all right up
next
what do you remember about working with
snakes including 120-pound albino python
on the [ __ ] music video set okay so boom
cardi was like megan i really want to do
a scene with snakes and i was like cardi
you want to do a scene with some snakes
like some real life snacks and i like
y'all don't want to just edit them in
there like she's like no we got to do it
with real snakes so i'm like
okay if cardi b saying she wanted me to
lay down with some snakes i guess i got
to lay down with the snakes
so we get there
i'm like all right i got to meet these
snakes before i jump in this damn pit
when we laid down i had made a little
friend a little bestie it was a little
green snake i don't know if y'all know
if y'all noticed that it was like one
green snake like we was killing it the
whole time because that was my little
friend but i met these snakes before we
laid down and i felt like we was keeping
the peace and then like the whole time i
was laying there
carter's like make it back
and then the music was starting we'll be
like yeah beat it up baby
trying to be all sexy still but we were
scared as hell like these snakes was
doing their own thing and i was like
damn you got me out here in the [ __ ]
snake pit carter
if we get bit the [ __ ] up like this song
better go number one
but he did so it was great
all right megan are you ready to move on
here to the back i'm actually scared
because this one snuck up on me so i
don't know
what the [ __ ] senor but you the
cucaracha about to do
[Music]
i ain't gonna talk [ __ ] yet
it's not
hot but it's nasty
[Laughter]
i don't like that
so you're a rapper and also a student as
we enter the hot nerd fall semester
we'll be here i'm graduating
this semester right yes we're approached
congratulations
on the topic of school do you have a
happiest memory from your time as a
member of the panther doll dancers right
oh my god yes how do you know that
um
my happiest memory as a parent at all i
guess when i made the team because i had
tried out for the team my first year
and i didn't make it
and when i tried out again i didn't make
it so i was like hell yeah but i really
built like a really good bond with a lot
of those girls and when i was first
coming up some of them was dancing for
me on the road so like we got to take it
you know off the basketball court to
stages and all the first stages i first
ever performed on so i was that's a good
memory for me
all right megan the stallion
are you ready to move on here okay
because the last one
y'all tried to feed me lake water so
let's see see what we'll see what we got
on deck over here and then how you say
this uh the lengua de fuego okay
this might be some [ __ ]
oh this smell hot
my nose burns okay
i feel like i keep anticipating it being
hot
like maybe you know you're playing
psychological games on yourself
in addition to your hard-hitting dents
with wordplay rap style there's also a
clear r b influence from even on the
latest project your song freaky girls
has the adina howard's sample to it and
then even one of your first original
songs like a stallion has a genuine sort
of like a pony vibe to it
and the great r b tradition of creating
songs to make love to what are the most
essential ingredients to a freak anthem
okay
i want to answer your question
but the peppers dancing on my tongue
yeah yeah yeah it's the show okay
because it why is this kicking in five
minutes later okay you want to know what
is the ingredients to making a good sex
song yeah that's what you said did you
just like love making it i i did you
know
yeah yeah use that okay the good
ingredients to a good love making song
first of all you need to have that good
baseline that good drum pattern so you
could be on rhythm
you got to match the strokes
to the drums if you cannot match the
stroke to the beat it ain't heat
but um and then like you just gotta have
somebody that can really sing like
like not seeing the thing because when
somebody can sing you know you really
feel it in your soul so it's like you
you got oh whoa you know like the riffs
like you know when somebody say that
they bout to sing okay they're about to
sing so yeah you just gotta had a good
voice and you gotta have a good
baseline and drum pattern
notes taken yes
on paper part of the record are you
ready to move on here to the next sauce
this is the bomb beyond insanity beyond
insanity you know this about to be hot
because this label looked homemade right
like they made this in their basement
it's like very uh mixtape sort of right
give them this [ __ ] they're gonna [ __ ]
this that fire
i'm cooking up some hot [ __ ] in my
basement you don't even know yeah this
look like some underground [ __ ]
[Music]
are you taking a small bite
i'll go with wherever you go with it you
know let's take a good bite all right
all right
because i see you breaking [ __ ] in half
throwing it in the trash
i don't like that
all right ready i'm ready okay
that's why i was going with the
the half
we gotta do it big yeah
i know
[Music]
this [ __ ] rattling my sinuses yeah
that's that
yeah
that's that one
i know i know you you and me same page
on that one
i've done this for a long time it never
gets any easier
the
like activated
but while you worked through that one
she got us [ __ ] up
as we've touched on a little bit today
you always proudly represent houston
texas so what i want to do is play a
little game called
hot girl [ __ ] or not hot girl [ __ ] where
i'll give you a few things that are
unique to houston and you just tell me
if it's hot girl [ __ ] or not hot girl
[ __ ]
ah
i cannot stand milk but
i need port in a storm you know
crush that water
the turkey leg hut
how girl [ __ ]
so i moved out of houston right when it
opened
so i literally when i pop in
i have to have somebody like just go
sneak and grab it for me right quick
[Applause]
the turkey just be falling right off the
bone
why is this hot sauce going like playing
tag with like my tongue my lips og ron c
mixtapes
hi girl shield
gotta be chopping off slop
being stuck in traffic on the 610
annoying girl [ __ ]
hate that [ __ ]
i used to be going to the gallery all
the time just get stuck
cute as [ __ ] in the car for hours
all right maggie how you feeling
i feel like this should be illegal i
feel like it got a radioactive sign
because this [ __ ] was made at area 51 or
some [ __ ]
this is some alien ass hot sauce
whoever made this [ __ ] need to be in
prison
[Music]
this my boy that looked like a boogeyman
werewolf this just like cranked i'm
scared
yeah you'll be quiet okay cause you're a
deceiver
and i'll step on the gas i'll step on
the gas to bring us to the punch line
here the only way i can do it is if we
just keep going we are going to go fast
we're going to go fast
so despite your high energy dancing on
stage you stay committed to live vocals
do you have a lesson about breath
control that you can maybe pass on to
the aspiring pop stars who may be
watching right now my mom definitely
taught me
take the breath at the right time
because when i used to rap i'll be
trying to spit it all out at one time
no she's like man you need to catch your
breath at the perfect word that work for
you
so yeah that's what i do well that's
great advice all right megan the
stallion
[Music]
you don't have to if you don't want to
well you doing this so i feel like
respect i'm just not gonna [ __ ] out
[ __ ]
should i take the last dab
all right girl
why this [ __ ] all stuck up at the top
like this
oh no
it's a little little wipe off a little
wipe off on that
i'm going out with a bang going out with
a bang a bang
cheers ah what are you doing smell like
about to hurt me
[Music]
right right
bringing it home bringing it home
begging the stallion mercifully we've
reached the conclusion of our meal
together and as your fans the hotties
know there's many sides of megan the
stallion these stage names the alter
egos the akas that you have on stage i'm
not gonna make you jump to a bunch of
hoops just gonna point to one simple hot
sauce to bomb beyond insanity and you
tell me the first megan the stallion
alter ego that comes to mind and why
hi girl meg
spicy as [ __ ] hot as [ __ ] you can't take
me
that's that
light that [ __ ] up
mike dropped from megan the stallion and
look at you taking on the wings of death
talking a little in the front half
having that returned a little bit in the
second half but making it through like
an absolutely champion look at you
and now there's nothing left to do but
roll out the red carpet for you this
camera this camera this camera let the
people know what you have going on in
your life oh my god
let me gather my thoughts
let me gather my taste buds gather my
composure
i told y'all we graduated december 11th
so that's the first thing i want to tell
y'all the second thing i want to tell
y'all
my friend it's only right that i gift
you
the hottie sauce
that i have coming out with popeyes you
are the first one with the official
bottle
and um this is not like
this goddamn
meth hot sauce that you got cooking up
in here
but there's some good [ __ ] i can't wait
to try it i can't wait to try it yeah
your official hot boy i'll take that
thank you for killing my tongue
alice if you like cruelty
by this
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh god
i made it through
and you wouldn't took me out if you
wouldn't gave me this goddamn
dagger in a bottle you know what you i
didn't take you out i i tried as hard as
i could to take you out i couldn't take
you out
as long as you knew nothing yeah
this was fun
hot ones truth or dab the game the kick
comes complete with 250 question cards
and then here's how the game works you
just go around the table you take turns
being the host being the players and
when you're a player you get asked a
question you have a choice just like in
the show answer it honestly or suffer
the wrath of the last dab and take a
look at this there's even a mini bottle
of the last dab included i suggest you
have napkins on hand you have to have
some milk on hand and of course be
careful be very careful around the eyes
hot ones truth or dab the play at home
game is available at
shop.firstwefs.com heatness.com and
amazon play at your own risk
wings not included
[Music]